china ha intensificado hoy su cruzada
contra las que tomo ned as el banco
central y otras nueve entidades
gubernamentales las han declarado
ilegales y han prohibido todas las
transacciones con ellas asegura china
que pretende luchar contra la
especulación y proteger tanto el orden
financiero y económico como las
propiedades de los particulares también
las acusa de estar detrás de delitos
como el lavado de dinero el fraude o las
estructuras piramidales la medida ha
provocado el inmediato desplome de
algunas de ellas por ejemplo bitcoin se
ha dejado el 5 por ciento de su
cotización en apenas unos minutos la
industria había florecido en china hasta
el punto de que 2 de cada 3 bitcoins
terminaban aquí hasta que algunos
gobiernos provinciales empezaron a
prohibir la actividad por el alto coste
energético que suponía esa prohibición a
partir de ahora
alcanza la escala nacional china es muy
celosa de todas las cuestiones
relacionadas con su soberanía también de
la monetaria y desconfiado un sistema de
pago que escapa de su control la medida
llega además cuando lidia con una
tormenta económica de dimensiones aún
desconocida por la falta de liquidez de
evergrande una de sus inmobiliarias más
grandes